así que tengo este bloque de madera aquí
tenemos este bloque de madera que tiene
una masa de 5 kilogramos 5 kilogramos y
está reposando sobre digamos no sé sobre
tierra y nos encontramos cerca de la
superficie terrestre ahora aquí tenemos
nuestro coeficiente de fricción el
coeficiente de fricción estática que es
de 0 0.60 para este tipo de madera y
este tipo de tierra en particular y el
coeficiente de fricción cinética entre
los mismos tipos de materiales es de
0.55 que y esto fue medido por alguien
hace no sé muchísimo tiempo o quizás lo
pudiste hallar en algún libro que se yo
digamos que empujamos de este lado de
este lado izquierdo del bloque con 100
newtons ok
aplicamos una fuerza de 100 newtons de
este lado de la caja entonces la
pregunta es qué va a pasar
bueno en principio si uno supone que no
hay fricción que no hay resistencia del
aire entonces solo tenemos una fuerza
a horizontal verdad solo tenemos una
fuerza horizontal y eso me va a producir
una aceleración porque nosotros sabemos
que toda fuerza produce una aceleración
y está determinada por esta relación
verdad la fuerza es igual a la masa por
la aceleración entonces si nosotros
tenemos una fuerza de 100 newtons y una
masa de 5 entonces podemos despejar la
aceleración como fuerza entre masa y
tendríamos 100 sobre 5 nos da una
aceleración de 20 metros sobre segundo
al cuadrado pero esto es suponiendo que
no hay fricción muy bien entonces qué
pasaría si si hay fricción entonces sí
si hay fricción uno tiene que considerar
mucho los coeficientes de fricción
estática o cinética verdad y recordemos
que el coeficiente de fricción estática
es la norma la norma de la fuerza porque
recordemos que la fuerza es un vector
digamos que empieza a provocar el
movimiento verdad esto es digamos
como un valor una fuerza umbral a partir
del cual la caja empezaría a acceder al
movimiento y estaba dividido entre la
fuerza de contacto verdad la fuerza de
contacto que hay entre estos dos
materiales y que eso no es otra cosa más
que la fuerza normal verdad entonces
nosotros tenemos esta relación que nos
da el coeficiente de fricción estática
entonces en principio uno podría
utilizar este coeficiente que por cierto
es una cantidad a dimensional para poder
tratar de de ver cuál es la fuerza a
partir del cual una una caja de madera y
con este tipo de suelo empieza a acceder
al movimiento ok entonces uno tiene que
checar que si éstos se encuentran sobre
la superficie terrestre tiene una fuerza
de atracción hacia el centro de la
tierra d
que habría que calcular la verdad lo que
sabemos es que la aceleración que
provoca es de 9.8 metros sobre segundo
al cuadrado y tenemos una masa de 5
kilogramos entonces si multiplicamos 5
por 9.8 eso nos da 49 49 newtons muy
bien ahora bien nosotros sabemos que
esta caja no permanece acelerando hacia
el centro de la tierra por por a lo
largo del tiempo entonces hay una fuerza
que es justamente la fuerza normal la
fuerza normal que va en dirección
contraria a la fuerza de gravedad que
tiene la misma magnitud verdad entonces
son 49 newtons pero hacia arriba verdad
y esto hace que al cancelarse el objeto
permanezca digamos en reposo entonces de
esta forma uno ya sabe cuál es la fuerza
normal y la fuerza normal entonces son
49 newtons esto nos dice cuál es digamos
la fuerza umbral a la que empieza a
acceder el movimiento entonces sabemos
qué
fuerza la fuerza digamos que empieza a
acceder al movimiento es igual a 49
newtons por 0.60 verdad por 0.60 y esto
en realidad como es una cantidad que no
tiene digamos unidades no tiene esa
dimensión al entonces esto se mantiene
todavía de newtons y esto nos da vamos a
ver
sacarnos
la calculadora ahí está y multiplicamos
49 x 0.60 y eso nos da 29.4 muy bien
entonces tenemos una fuerza ok que va en
esta dirección contraria verdad tenemos
una fuerza digamos no sé vamos a
pintarla aquí que va en dirección
contraria al movimiento que es la fuerza
de fricción ok que es de 29.4 newtons y
lo pongo aquí porque en realidad ésta se
genera en el contacto también digamos a
nivel atómico entre la caja y el suelo
verdad entonces lo que tenemos es lo
siguiente estamos aplicando una fuerza
de 100 newtons pero hay una fuerza de
fricción hacia la izquierda que va en
dirección contraria al movimiento de
29.4 newtons muy bien entonces cuál es
la fuerza neta que obtenemos bueno pues
simplemente sería cosa de a 100
quitarle 29.4 ya son quizás puede
haberlo hecho sin usar la calculadora
zone no además de nuevo 100 menos 29.4
es que había puesto más y esos son 70.6
entonces tenemos una fuerza neta que va
hacia la derecha hacia la derecha de
70.6 newtons y recordemos que esto de
aquí sólo es para un momento en
particular sólo es para un momento ok
esto es en el momento en el que empieza
a acceder la caja al movimiento en el
que empieza a moverse ok casi podríamos
pensar que que no dura nada de hecho
pues es en un único momento del tiempo
verdad y ahora ya que tenemos esta
fuerza podríamos pensar cuál es la
aceleración entonces tenemos 70.6 es la
fuerza y tenemos la masa que es de 5 si
nosotros dividimos esto entre sí
nos da 14.1 digamos 14.1 metros sobre
segundo cuadrado
entonces la aceleración que provoca es
de 14.1 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
esta es la aceleración que provoca en
este único momento del tiempo ok una vez
que empieza a acceder al movimiento ya
no nos importa el coeficiente de
fricción estática ahora el que es
importante es el cuatri el coeficiente
de fricción cinética porque ya hay un
movimiento ok entonces ya que tenemos
este movimiento recordemos que el
coeficiente de fricción cinética no es
otra cosa más que la proporción que hay
entre la fuerza de fricción
/ la fuerza de contacto que es la fuerza
normal verdad y todo esto va en norma
ahora otra vez nosotros ya sabemos
cuánto vale esto esto es de 49 minutos
pero de esta relación no puede darse
cuenta que mientras más se presiones
mientras más se presionen es decir
mientras más hay hay más
más fuerte es el contacto entre estas
dos estos dos objetos entonces vamos a
requerir mucha más fuerza de fricción
para mantener esta esta constante pues
justamente así que sea una constante
verdad entonces si es más grande la
fuerza normal la fuerza de fricción
tiene que ser mucho más grande y va a ir
en contra del movimiento entonces lo que
tenemos es que nuestra fuerza de
fricción nuestra fuerza de fricción será
49 newtons 49 newtons multiplicado por
la el coeficiente de fricción cinética
que es 0.55
entonces 49 si lo multiplicamos por 0.55
nos da 26.95 y esto va a ser newtons
26.95 newtons y ahí lo tienen entonces
en este caso si esta caja y empieza
digamos a moverse hacia la derecha
entonces vamos a tener una fuerza de
fricción que va en contra del movimiento
que podríamos calcular muy bien de hecho
es 26.95 entonces piensa que ahora
tenemos aquí una fuerza de fricción de
26.95 y en realidad lo estoy poniendo no
sea arbitrariamente en este lugar pero
todo debería estar pensado aquí en el
centro de masa de este objeto verdad
para que digamos para ser un poquito más
formales pero vamos a darnos el lujo por
un momento de ponerlo aquí ok entonces
esta es nuestra fuerza de fricción
nuestra fuerza de fricción tenemos que
la tenemos que hacer la operación
correspondiente con la fuerza que
estamos aplicando para saber cuál es la
fuerza neta muy bien
entonces la fuerza neta es es la
siguiente vamos a ver tenemos 100
100 - 26.95 punto 95 y eso nos da 70
73.0 cinco minutos entonces tenemos una
fuerza neta hacia la derecha de 73
puntos 0 5 minutos ok y de hecho el caso
anterior era de 29.4 minutos ok entonces
tenemos una fuerza neta de 73 puro punto
0 5 minutos esta es nuestra fuerza neta
para cuando ya se está moviendo nuestra
caja ahora cual es la aceleración que
provoca esta fuerza la aceleración pues
será la fuerza dividida entre la masa
entonces aquí tenemos nuestra fuerza y
si dividimos entre 5 que es la masa
tenemos 14.61 metros 14.61 metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado y hay que decir
hacia donde verdad y esto es a la
derecha porque estas son unidades
vectoriales muy bien entonces vamos a
hacer un breve resumen que fue lo que
pasó al inicio teníamos una aceleración
de 14.1 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
sólo en un único momento en un único
momento que es cuando empieza a acceder
la caja al movimiento verdad y si t pues
si te das cuenta teníamos una
aceleración mucho bueno no sé si mucho
menor pero sí menor que la que tenemos
cuando ya empieza a moverse entonces una
vez que se dio digamos
suponiendo que seguimos aplicando la
misma fuerza de 100 newtons y que es
constante entonces la fuerza de está va
a ser mayor pues la fuerza de fricción
es mucho menor debido a que a lo mejor
ya no tienen que ya no están tan en bonn
hadas las las moléculas a nivel atómico
entonces esto provoca que haya una mayor
aceleración